excitement can you feel it keep building
a little bit here in the valley the las
vegas raiders will kick off their season
monday night at a legion stadium we've
told you if you're going you have to be
vaccinated at least partially vaccinated
but that becomes a little difficult
getting in and out so hector mohan
joining us live from allegiance stadium
this morning with what you need to know
because they want to make this quick and
efficient
yeah that's the goal good morning to you
heather and john but there's a lot of
different things you can do to prove the
vaccination status well the raiders made
the announcement set the new rules a few
weeks ago when governor steve sissellac
announced that venues and events can set
their own rules and there's now an
alternate screening happening over at
that parking lot across the street that
is parking lot b and that is meant to
make the screening process a lot easier
the team announced wednesday that they
will open alternate screening ahead of
time and have a vaccination clinic on
site so you can get your first shot on
the spot if you wish raiders officials
say they hope the flexibility encourages
as many fans as possible to still come
to the game we try to create a lot of
options but like you said the most
important thing is for people to act
early and to be prepared do it that one
time well in advance to game day so that
you can fly through the gates easily and
be in the stadium
all right so we have the breakdown the
full breakdown on our website
eightnewsnow.com also one thing to note
if you are fully vaccinated you can
download and use the clear app that will
get you straight through the door once
you prove the that you have the clear
app and that you have downloaded all of
your information however if you are
partially vaccinated you will have to
use the alternate screening and you will
have to keep your mask on during the
game reporting live hector mejia 8 news
now back to you